oh big brother there's no one else like you mom and dad may call you a
disappointment all the kids at school call you weird and stinky and creepy
and stinky but they're all wrong not about being stinky though but it's my
favorite stench sure you're a general pervert to most women in town you dress
like you're homeless you went to juvie twice before the age of 12 but they're
all wrong about you all of them every single cop and priest and guidance
counselor and medical professional and fast food cashier all the funny pranks
we used to do our big big heists our nights together I miss them I know it's
been a while since I last saw you I'm sorry you might not care but mom and dad
stop talking about you for a while now they act like you never existed they
smile a lot more now as if they didn't see what I saw so I left them I don't
need them anyway when I have you back all we'll need is each other and they
don't even know I found your book so they don't know that I can bring you back
I don't want to mess it up like last time and the time before that but don't make
fun of me I was new at it so I'm gonna be a big pro before I bring back my big
bro oh right last time we talked you said someone was keeping you from coming
back well that's what I figured between all your screaming you were probably a
pro at this magical stuff huh big bro which means they must be real nasty to
be able to keep you from coming back I'm still starting out so I make lots of
mistakes but I'm not scared I've been practicing all over town I'm leveling up
so I can smash the final boss as soon as I see him and then I'll find them got
them bring you back and then we can everything will be perfect yeah I don't
care who it is ghost an angel or even the devil herself you're gonna be back
home again and we can finally I hope you can still hear me no I know you can I
know you do the same for me so never think that I'll quit I'll tear through
hell and earth myself if I have to I'll practice and practice and practice and
when I'm the perfect woman for you I will take you home wait for me I'll see
you later big bro